bonjour vous pourriez m'aider à ouvrir
la porte s'il vous plaît vous avez les
clés
le trou de la serrure il est là non non
tu la vois pas
et voir quoi vous
foutez mes clés là
vous me donnez un trousseau de 50 avec
ça
je sais pas moi vous voyez mieux que moi
quand même là regardez
vous voyez bien que
je sais bien excusez-moi mais vous me
donnez un trousseau de clé il y en a
partout les clés
j'ai des clés à côté de des clés de ma
voiture oh non arrêtez bah si vous
connaissez votre sauce
avec vous avez vu et vous voyez machin
je trouve ça c'est plus drôle maintenant
trouver la clé vous trouvez la clé
alors faut sortir alors faut sortir
et appeler le Père Fouras
maintenant
ça y est c'est ouvert non non
excusez merci au revoir
[Musique]